I think you made reference last time we
talked to uh uranium uh oh yeah you know
that was an industry units yeah are you
still hot on that or absolutely
absolutely I mean let's go through all
of the mistakes that have been made in
the European Union uh in relationship to
uh to Putin Russia and Ukraine I mean
the first thing that they do is they
come out and they do all these sanctions
well how did that work out for him right
I would argue that those sanctions
impacted the European Union far more
negatively than it impacted Russia but
you see that the price of energy just
absolutely skyrockets to the point
unfortunately where this winter a lot of
people over there might not be able to
afford uh you know just heating their
home which is by the way is another
problem that we have here in the United
States with diesel up in the the
Northeast as a result of these crazy
policies towards uh Russia which you
know I'm no fan of Russia but I am a fan
of doing something to them that will
hurt us less
than it hurts them
you know kind of Common Sense and a
cost-benefit analysis but anyway you
know let's go back to 1980 and we had
the green or maybe it was 78 that's when
the green party started in Germany and
their Battle Cry one of their battle
cries back then Rich was to get rid of
nuclear we got to get rid of nuclear got
to get rid of nuclear so long in the
1990s Along Comes this politician who's
of course Machiavellian and he sees an
opportunity there he doesn't give a he
doesn't care about the polar bears or
you know the the temperature in the
ocean he just sees this as an
opportunity to use power and control
his name is Gerhard Schroeder so Gerhard
Schroeder comes along he says okay green
party I'll go ahead and Pander to you
guys if you if we if if and at the time
he wasn't part of the green party but he
kind of combined them and he said okay
if I get elected then I'm going to go
ahead and get rid of all this dirty
horrible horrible uh nuclear energy so
he does that in the early 2000s he gets
rid of the nuclear energy but what does
he replace it with he replaces it with a
pipeline going straight to Russia for
gnat gas called Nordstrom maybe you've
heard of it yeah right so in an effort
to Pander to his constituents they take
a source of of a very very clean energy
and they replace it with something
that's far more detrimental to the
environment and they make their self
completely dependent uh upon Russian Nat
gas and therefore giving Putin all the
leverage in the world
and so fast forward to today when they
go ahead and Implement these sanctions
now what do they trans because they
don't have the net gas so what are they
having to transition to well now they're
having to use more coal Coal Rich coal
than they ever have in the last let's
say 30 or 40 years and they're some
people are literally having to go out
and cut down Timberwood like in their
backyard just to heat their house which
has probably a bigger impact on the
environment than coal does so my point
here is that all these Central planners
and authoritarians and all these people
excuse me
that are really malthusians at heart I
call them the malthusian cult and that's
the world economic Forum that's the the
EU the un uh the IMF and all of their
cronies and unfortunately they've got a
lot of influence over Corporate America
as well but these people truly believe
that there are too many human beings on
the planet Earth relative to the amount
of scarce resources we have so they have
two objectives one is to make sure that
people use less energy
and they're doing a very good job of
that right now in Europe and number two
is to decrease the population like Bill
Gates always talks about but you know
they won't say well we want to actually
kill people but we they'll say well we
want to reduce the population uh growth
or we want to reduce the birth rate
something like that so these and these
are their two objectives going all the
way back to when Klaus started the world
economic Forum in 1971 right and uh the
club of Rome in 1968 you guys can can do
all the research I've done a lot of
whiteboard videos on this but the point
here is that climate change is just a
trojan horse it's just a way to to allow
them to use a marketing tool right to
really package what their true
objectives are because using less energy
therefore lowering the standard of
living for the entire globe or just
killing you know half the people half
the population you know call it four
billion people that that doesn't really
sell so you you've got you got to use
some marketing strategy there and
package it a different way so my point
is we see this climate change narrative
and I'm all for clean air I want to be
very very clear but what I'm saying is
the people pushing this narrative most
of them especially at the top they don't
care about clean air they only care
about those two objectives usurping
power and control right so what do you
think's in it for them because I always
like to ask that that question when it
comes to these ideas like what's in it
for these conglomerates to to reduce and
eliminate more of the population
there are several things there first and
foremost it's their it's their religion
they truly believe they're doing good
so I think if you and I sat down with
Klaus
and had a couple beers I I don't think
he would come out and say
I just I love murdering people I think
he would
exactly right exactly I think he would
say listen uh the fact of the matter is
that Thomas Malthus was right that we
have if we have exponential population
growth in a world with limited resources
at some point that has to bring down the
standard of living for all the people in
the world because energy is the economy
people have to realize that you can you
can uh look at a chart of our energy use
globally and it tracks perfectly with
GDP growth and the global population
so as if we have access to more and more
energy if we're able to use more energy
that's going to increase the standard of
living for the people in aggregate total
so if we have access to less energy
because the population is growing
exponentially and the energy the amount
of energy you have access to Flat lines
the only thing that can happen is the
standard of living coming down
so Klaus would say we don't want that to
happen
so in order to prevent that
unfortunately we've got to make some
hard decisions
and a hard decision is we've got to
create an equilibrium between the
population and the environment in which
we live in the amount of resources that
we have access to and in order to do
that you've got to reduce uh the energy
use in the rich countries and you've got
to reduce the population in the poor
countries and why would he say that
because the poor countries are the ones
that they really have to focus on
because they're the ones that go from
first of all right now they're using a
lot less energy than we are in the west
right and if you've ever been to like
Ecuador or something like that you know
what I'm talking about they're just
they're living in a you know a brick
kind of Hut thing here and uh they're
riding around on a bicycle but what
happens is as their standard or as their
GDP grows then they use more and more
energy because they go from riding a
bicycle
to riding a scooter
and then they go from riding a scooter
to driving a little car and then they go
to driving a truck and then they're what
they eat changes as well they go from
just eating rice and then they start
eating more and more protein while
protein requires a lot of energy and so
the the the Klaus types they see that
and they say okay well we can't we
understand that human beings are
hardwired to always want something
better for themselves and for their
children and for the generations to come
so we can't prevent them from going from
a bicycle to a moped that ain't gonna
happen so what we have to do is we just
have to lower the population in those
areas that have those types of opera or
that you know basically uh everyone is
going to want that opportunity so we
just have to decrease the population in
aggregate total now I think they'd say
that you know maybe after two beers
Klaus would say okay well we want to do
that by just discouraging population
growth just like the one child policy in
China as an example so we just want to
you know promote uh
birth control or we want to promote the
idea that people should just have one
child or two children order but I think
after about four or five beers then
you'd it would turn a little darker as
far as the conversation and it would go
from well we need to promote uh having
fewer children to we need to enforce
this from a top-down standpoint and then
maybe after 10 beers you'd get to the
the Thanos plan which is what I call it
and if you saw that movie uh exactly you
got it you got it so so I mean here's
what's really interesting about that I
know Justin Trudeau is one of Klaus
Schwab's best buddies oh he's a disciple
he's like a cloud Schwab mini me yeah
and there was um there was an article or
a uh or a conversation piece that came
out for Max Bernier who's like the main
opposition who doesn't even have a seat
in Parliament but he's he's the guy
saying you know we need we we need a
little more freedom less rules lower tax
taxes you know get out of my life stay
out of my pockets and get the hell out
of here sort of thing and
Trudeau's been talking about increasing
the immigration rates into Canada which
kind of contrasts you know the whole
notion of lowering population population
density energy usage and all that right
and I think the number was doubling if
I'm not mistaken so why
double your immigration rates into
Canada if you're drunk on the cloud
Schwab Kool-Aid to lower the population
reduce population lower energy
consumption when that in theory would be
the opposite do you have any thoughts on
that yeah I do I think number one it's
part of this woke narrative so a lot of
times that conflicts with the overall
main objectives of the global disease
but also too if you look at what truly
does lower population it's when people
become richer
so and Bill Gates will tell you that
it's when people become healthier that
that's complete BS he's just trying to
sell you uh you know some oceanfront
property in Arizona just to push his his
narrative but when when people get
richer they do have fewer kids
and so that could be it when they're
trying to bring all these people from
maybe poor countries into the Richer
countries assuming that their standard
of living will increase therefore
they'll reproduce a lot less
that's an interesting Theory okay
so take them out of environment where
they'd normally have four four or five
kids put them in one while I might have
one or two yeah exactly and not only
that but to put them into an environment
where they will vote for you so you can
continually stay in power well
there's probably a lot of uh of
reasons why they may push that narrative
or that agenda
it doesn't seem to be slowing down
though does it
yeah yeah what I always say is that
every night I go to bed and I think to
myself well the good news is it can't
get any crazier
and then I wake up the next morning and
read the news you know I
I you know it's funny I um you know I
did this reaction piece to Jordan
Peterson's three-part series on The
Daily wire about encouraging guys to
marry
um if you haven't seen it you should go
watch it on the unplugged Alpha podcast
it's it's from like two weeks ago and
because I subscribed to the Daily wire I
figured you know I'd check out what was
on and I saw this one that caught my eye
which was
um what is a Woman by Matt Walsh and oh
right I don't know that was a 90-minute
train wreck like by the end of it I you
know by the time I was done I just
looked at my my girl and I was like I
don't really belong in this world like I
don't agree with any of this that's not
me I'm not like I don't I'm not not in
my head here it's just I I can totally
relate Rich you know totally related
it's like where are we going here man
like is this really what's becoming so
common and every time you know I look
around it's like well that's batshit
crazy and there's more of this batshit
crazy stuff over here and it's like am I
the only one that's still sane
hmm
you know that you know that whole code
in The Matrix sort of thing I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out